Why do you recommend that cancer patients should eat meat?
I thought we should all be vegan.
Well, no, I don't think we should all be vegan.
Matter of fact, I don't think very many people at all should be vegan.
I think meat was for us to eat.
No, I'm not saying that, you know, I think everybody's different and everybody's unique.
There's some people that do much better on a more vegan diet.
Most of the people that are eating vegan are eating vegan for philosophical reasons, not necessarily health reasons.
Now, I know there's a lot of books out there forks over knife, said food revolution type books.
I don't know if that book itself is talking about veganism.
But it's unfortunate that when you find out that these books were sponsored by PETA organizations or something like that.
The author was paid by an organization that promotes veganism.
That's political agenda masking as science and masking as good exegesis of how our physiology works.
Because that's just not true.
There's a lot of people out there on the internet.
I see Instagram videos that people say we were not created to eat meat.
We were created to eat vegetables.
That's just total nonsense.
We were created to eat meat.
You know, maybe some people eat too much meat.
Maybe some people don't eat enough meat.
But certainly with cancer, the reason why I promote meat consumption with the majority of people that understand we test people as an individual and some people we take off meat.
That's why I don't think everybody should be vegan.
Why I feel very few people should be vegan, especially in the cancer realm, is that you need enough protein in order to make a certain type of white blood cell that will kill cancer.
So it is the T cells and natural killer cells that kill cancer cells.
And you need a lot of free amino acids.
The only way you're going to get that free amino acid content is to eat enough protein.
And most of the time cancer patients are already insufficient to their diet as far as how much they can eat.
They don't feel well.
They might have other comorbidities.
They may have comorbidities from their treatment via, let's say, if they're doing chemotherapy or immunotherapy, they're not feeling well.
You know, eat what they should be eating.
And they're very often deficient in protein.
In fact, that's one amino side that a person can have cancer is low blood protein levels.
So when you have a total protein or albumin levels and globular levels that are deficient, that is an amino side for possible cancer in itself.
So you need to consume enough protein in you could say, well, we can do that through our vegetables.
We can do that through this.
Well, maybe a healthy person can eat enough that but you really need to consume your weight, your desired weight.
So if you've already lost weight from cancer and you're below your desired weight, let's say your desired weight is 150 and you're at 135, you need to eat 150 grams of protein per day.
That's a lot of grams of protein per day.
Now, you can get that in if you eat too several pieces of chicken with your other diet.
But it's hard to get that in with protein shake or anything like that.
It's just very difficult to get that you need adequate amounts of protein to do that.
Plus protein, this way in red meat can help with red blood cell formation, which anemia is another major issue with cancer patients.
So please be aware that a lot of books that are on the market are not well balanced.
They have an agenda behind them. They're pushing a certain agenda.
They're pushing a certain philosophy, which is really a religion.
And it's not the religion that I adhere to.
So I don't think those those things are have as much value as some other people put on it.